WARNING NOW, AS MANY AS A
QUARTER OF THE PEOPLE INFECTED
WITH CORONAVIRUS MAY NOT SHOW
ANY SYMPTOMS.
THE AGENCY NOW IS WEIGHING
WHETHER TO RECOMMEND ALL
AMERICANS WHERE A FACE MASK.
THAT’S BEEN A BIG DEBATE LAST
COUPLE DAYS.
WATCH THIS.
>> IF YOU ASSUME THAT 25% IS
ASYMPTOMATIC, THE ONLY WAY YOU
WOULD DO IT IS GOING TO AREAS
THAT ARE HIGH-TRANSITION ZONES
AND HAVE INDIVIDUALS THEN
WEARING MASKS.
ASSUMING THEY ARE INFECTED.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE DATA AND
THIS ISSUE OF WHETHER IT’S GOING
TO CONTRIBUTE IS BEING
AGGRESSIVELY REVIEWED AS WE
SPEAK.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, BRET,
YESTERDAY WE HEARD FROM THE U.S.
SURGEON GENERAL TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
HE DID MAKE A POINT, I THOUGHT
IT WAS INTERESTING.
IT MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER, YOU
CAN DO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
BUT YOU MIGHT END UP TOUCHING
YOUR FACE MORE IF YOU’RE WEARING
A MASK.
I MEAN, WE ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE, KIND OF, AND WHAT WE
THINK WE SHOULD BE DOING.
THE MESSAGES HAVE BEEN PRETTY
CONSTANT COMING OUT OF THE
OFFICIALS.
>> Bret: HARRIS, I THINK THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS COMING ONCE
THERE ARE ENOUGH N95 MASKS IN
CIRCULATION.
I THINK ALL THESE COMPANIES ARE
SPEEDING UP THE PRODUCTION, I DO
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE
THIS RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT YOU DON’T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE IT.
IF YOU ARE ASYMPTOMATIC, YOU
COULD STILL BE CARRYING THE
VIRUS AND YOU COULD BE
TRANSMITTING IT.
SO, WEARING A MASK MAY BE
SOMETHING THAT WE START SEEING
PEOPLE DO.
>> Harris: IT IS, TO BECOME A
CONFLICT OF MESSAGING, THOUGH.
TO TELL PEOPLE NOT TO WEAR THEM
IS ONE THING, BASED ON WHETHER
OR NOT IT WOULD PROTECT THEM.
BUT TO TELL THEM NOT TO WEAR
THEM UNTIL WE CATCH UP WITH N95
MASKS, WHERE THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL HAS THEM AND IT
REVEALS WEARS THEM, THOSE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT MESSAGES.
>> Bret: WHICH IS WHY THE
PRESIDENT SAID YOU HAVE A SCARF.
UNTIL WE GET THE MASKS, IF YOU